as of right now this is one of the
greatest mysteries in the wheel of time
after only watching the first three
episodes of the new show for the record
i have not read the book so i don't know
a whole lot of information about these
characters or this universe just yet i
only know what i have been shown in
those first three episodes released on
amazon
now based on what i have seen so far
moraine has said that she has learned of
a secret a vision of a baby being born
and according to her this baby will
change the world he or she can help save
them from the dark one who is waking his
whispers are already at the backs of
their minds and if moraine doesn't
succeed in finding this dragon reborn
the earth itself will burn and
everything will be consumed by darkness
she now knows that the last dragon was
reborn only she doesn't know who it is
either what she has said is she knows it
will be one of the main characters who
left the small village with her at the
beginning of this series those
characters are rand iguain matt and
peron one of them is most likely the
last dragon or the dragon reborn now you
have to remember i don't know anything
outside of what i have seen in the
handful of episodes on amazon however
with that being said i think i know who
it will be as of right now i think it
will be rand although i don't have a
whole lot of evidence to back that up
right now
you think it's one of them
which one
and who knows maybe i will end up
thinking it's someone else after i watch
a few more episodes but for now i do
think it is him honestly i'm not even
sure if i want to read any of the
comments on this video because i don't
want to be spoiled just yet however
leave me some of your thoughts down
below do any of you agree with me or do
you think it will be someone else now if
you already know the answer because you
have read everything then maybe avoid
this discussion for right now anyways i
just wanted to throw out a short and
sweet video about this new show that i
am enjoying thus far i might even end up
grabbing some of the novels so i can
learn more about these characters and
the world they live in as always thank
you all for watching the video i hope
all of you have a great day and for
those of you who are celebrating the
holidays happy thanksgiving i will see
you all soon for the next video bye